Serial Killer Joe is back for the fourth
season of you searching as ever for
Redemption and now caught in the schemes
of a mysterious Eat the Rich murderer
yippikai movie lovers I'm Jan and in
this video I'm breaking down the big
twist in part one of season four Clues
you might have missed and predictions
for part two spoilers ahead of course so
take care
season 4 opens with Joe yet again
thinking he can put his murderous past
behind him this time going by the alter
ego Jonathan Moore an English literature
professor in London darling could be
your test he'll make some different
choices he then seemingly tries to stay
on the straight and narrow but gets
involved with a circle of wealthy
socialites and obnoxious British
Aristocrats and after a drunken night at
an exclusive Club he wakes up to find
Malcolm dead in his flat Joe disposes of
the body and begins receiving mysterious
messages from the Eat the Rich killer
who next dispatches Simon and Gemma in
the mid-season finale things come to a
head when the loaths of Aristo rolled
accuses Joe of being the Killer and
attempts to execute him by hunting him
through the woods Joe manages to stop
rolled but then Rhys turns up out of
nowhere and knocks him out Joe wakes up
and finds himself chained in a dungeon
with rolled and Rhys reveals he's behind
the murders
there were several Clues to the close
connection between Rhys and Joe right
from the first episode where we can see
how similar they are each having had
difficult childhoods and both being
raised by a single mother pleasure to
meet you brother in arms Reece spent
some time in prison when he was younger
and when he tells Joe that he relapsed
into alcoholism and fighting three times
before finally setting himself on a
better path it's a nod to Joe's three
attempts so far to change his own life
and Escape his murderous past in New
York first going to La then on to Madre
Linda and now to London and it's no
coincidence that Joe feels drawn to
someone who wrote a book titled a good
man in a cruel world so now I just tried
to do a bit of good moving forward to
something as it reflects Joe's frequent
misguided belief that he's really just a
good guy with Noble intentions he's
messed up a few times and who's just
trying to be better from now on Joe
clearly admires Rhys and his tale of how
he went from a council estate to Oxford
University and is now trying to become
mayor of London and so he asks him so
you believe it's possible Redemption I
think yes as long as they commit to
never run from themselves face it all no
matter what Embrace everything Jonathan
Rhys is telling Joe that he shouldn't
shy away from his darker side and I
think he actually sounds a lot like love
Quinn here someone who also blindsided
Joe when she revealed she was a brutal
killer just like him and who didn't
really regret her actions just like Rhys
doesn't in the mid-season reveal by the
way we haven't seen Joe's Infamous cage
that's appeared in every season of you
so far but it's interesting how Rhys
still found a Subterranean soundproof
dungeon underneath hamsbridge house in
which to lock up Joe and rolled there
are a few details and clues however that
hint at something more going on beneath
the surface first of all it seems
strange that Rhys is going on a murder
spree of his wealthy friends while
simultaneously making his become
mayor of London call me crazy feels like
they have a complicate lurking
anonymously to kill people
so having all of the murders apart from
one committed by someone other than Joe
seems
seems to be much of a repeat of of what
happened in season three as does having
an English version of Joe after we've
just had a female version of Joe in the
previous two seasons there's also
something odd about the way that Joe
always seems to be waking up just before
he discovers has been a murder for
example he was blackout drunk when
Malcolm was killed he fell asleep
outside the gallery when Simon died and
gemma's murder appeared to happen after
he was knocked out after falling through
the window at hampsbridge house there's
also the first message he receives from
the killer hello you which has a real
Vibe of Joe about it hello
you and let's not forget Nadia's first
rule about murder mysteries number one
there are no coincidences someone who's
also hiding some dark secrets is Kate
and her father who she described to Joe
as the worst man alive given what's been
teased already I'm sure we're going to
find out a lot more about him and Kate's
past in part two Kate told Joe that her
family is even richer than her old money
aristocratic friends and her father has
been involved in all manner of dodgy
dealings from corporate cover-ups to
falsifying environmental reports and I
suspect there may be some connection
between him and Rhys perhaps he's
funding Reese's election campaign in
return for dodgy favors or maybe more
likely given Reese's claims that he's
going to clean up the city perhaps
Kate's dad wants to take Rhys down so he
can carry on his own dirty business more
easily but despite Kate's protestations
that she doesn't want to be anything
like her father could there be something
she's not telling Joe there could be a
little clue in the first Miss Marple
novel The Murder at the vicarage that
Joe picks up when he decides to study
the whodunit genre in that story an
extremely unlikable magistrate is
murdered by his wife together with her
lover and they also plot to pin the
blame on someone else in you Rhys
confesses that his original plan was to
frame Joe for the murder of Malcolm who
like the magistrate in the Miss Marple
book was also hated by everyone around
him Malcolm is trash and if we take the
Agatha Christie novel as a clue it could
suggest that Malcolm's girlfriend Kate
was somehow also involved as well as
having a similar look to love Quinn Kate
also gives off shades of love from
season two who didn't care about Joe's
history of murdering back and actually
embraced his murderous past your past
doesn't scare me it can't be worse than
mine she even sounds a bit like Joe's
internal monologue here in the opening
episode good perfect you like all three
previous seasons of view of managed so
far I'm expecting part two to have some
shocking twists at the time of writing
this video I've only seen the first five
episodes but I'll have a stab pun
intended at some more predictions for
the season four finale I've always
thought that Joe's crimes will
eventually catch up with him and he'll
get caught due to his sloppy execution
at some point there is that jar of P at
the Salinger house after all if I did
caught with this blow heart it'd be
Poetic Justice whether it's this season
or a future final season I feel the time
is nearing for some of Joe's past to
eventually come back to bite him murder
has a way of following you and you're
not getting away with it Nadia will
surely play some part in the next
installment as she's been helping Joe
research who done it and always seems to
be popping up whenever he's up to
something I thought you were breaking in
or something nope sorry to disappoint
and perhaps you'll also end up with her
classroom rival Edward these two are
going to kill each other or get married
by the end of term Phoebe and Adam
clearly have a lot of issues to work
through to say the least and although
she said she was going to leave him she
seemed to get back together with him at
the end of the mid-season finale also I
wonder if we'll ever find out the
Apparently incredibly profound thing
that Joe said to Phoebe on that first
night at Adam's Club what you said to me
the other night I don't know that I've
ever been seen so completely a
suspicious character I noticed a couple
of times who seems to be following the
group around is this photographer here
who is watching them at Simon's funeral
Joe also ducked away from her when she
noticed him at Simon's art exhibition
this is actress Alison pargeter one of
whose best known roles was as a store
cut on the British soap EastEnders and
I'll expect we'll find out what she's up
to in part two also I wonder whether
we've seen the last of Marianne could
she come back and try and reveal Joe
Goldberg is actually still alive and
like I said in my original season 4
theories video back in 2021 I'd love to
see love Quinn somehow make a return
perhaps as a hallucination to haunt Joe
from Beyond the Grave like has done
before and there's a part 2 preview
which you might have missed at the end
of the credits for episode 5 the teaser
shows love in what I think is the cage
and interestingly she's holding Reese's
book a good man in a cruel world I think
this is probably still just a dream or
the ghost of Love Quinn but either way I
can't wait to see her return and if you
enjoyed this video do leave a thumbs up
I really appreciate it thanks for
enjoying you with me and hope you have a
marvelous movie loving week yippee Kai
movie lovers